نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
واحدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقلى عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله ضرب البيوت
استقروا هنا على الحدود التشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20,000 لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه كفرون
تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه وضروره
تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوان
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحه عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات